[Music]
for our 42nd season
the greatest social experiment on
television
continues
i'm so proud to be a canadian and also
to be a canadian minority you know i
never saw a lot of indians or muslims on
the tv screen growing up i'm an exotic
animal veterinarian i'm gonna be like
the owl in the night you're not gonna
see me coming until you're dead
and so to be so welcomed by survivor and
have canada so excited it shows that
everybody does belong and we're all just
like each other even if we look
different
the thing that pushed me to audition for
survivor is that i love the show and
then i realized they were accepting
canadians and i'm like hey if i love it
so much i'm always saying let me put my
money where my mouth is so i listed i'm
weird and i'm here to show the people
you can be here too and you can win
i thought that they must have called the
wrong
person i'm a smart business woman i'm
taking down very smart businessmen
it's life-changing and for me being in
the game i realized that like wow
this is more than just a game this is
an inner challenge
the bar is high erica really did super
well on season 41 the winner of survivor
41 erica and coming into the game i also
know that there's never been an indian
or a muslim winner and there hadn't been
a canadian winner up until erica so the
pressure is high to perform on my
favorite show of all time
even before erica i knew that there was
going to be pressure because
it's real
it's real it's real it's real
as a canadian i'm pumped
we're just such a diverse country and
we're all here and ready to play
you